[Aplausos]
quien de ustedes vive de lo que soñó
cuando eran pequeños
hace algunos años una niña mirando
televisión de una gimnasia olímpica
estadounidense que estaba tener una
participación en un mundial o algo por
el estilo quedó totalmente enamora de lo
que hacía corría brincaba volaba casi
casi como una superhéroe y dijo ya sé
que quiero hacer cuando sea grande ella
vivía en escuinapa sinaloa ma y pues en
aquellos años muy apenas había escuelas
entonces era difícil que hubiera una
escuela de gimnasia suerte cambio en el
año 95
sus papás son maestros y trabajaban en
mazatlán todos los días se levantaban
alrededor de las 4 o 5 de la mañana para
tomar un autobús e irse a trabajar y
regresaban por ahí de las 4 de la tarde
pero este año ellos tomaron la decisión
de irse a vivir a mazatlán
definitivamente ellos iban en busca de
una mejor vida para la familia pero esa
niña ahora sí iba en busca de su primera
escuela de gimnasia
tomó su primer clase de gimnasia de los
siete años un poco grande para brillar
en un deporte tan demandante como ese
opinión de varias personas pese a eso se
esforzó muchísimo al año y estaba el
nivel de varias niñas que tenían 23 años
entrenando todo a perfecto la escuela
bien sus entrenamientos bien su hora
favorita del día era a la hora de
entrenar sentía que había nacido para
eso a pesar de no tener una
infraestructura tan grande como en otras
ciudades
ella estaba decidida y comprometida a
esforzarse muchísimo llegó a soñar lo
que sueñan muchos niños deportistas ir a
juegos olímpicos representar a su país y
sobre todo hacer que sus papás se
sintieran muy orgullosos de ella porque
sabía el esfuerzo que hacían para que
ella pudiera realizar ese deporte
tu espalda está muy lastimada por eso
tus piernas no responden necesitas
aguantar un tiempo con asistencia hasta
para ir al baño si sales de esta opino
que nunca más podrás hacer deporte con
ningún tipo de actividad pesada porque
corres el riesgo de lastimar más tu
columna y ahora así podrás quedarte en
silla de ruedas para siempre
imagínate un doctor diciendo estas
palabras que sentirías tú que te las
dijeran
ahora
imagínate una niña de 11 años que amaba
el deporte escuchando las
qué crees que sintió
esa niña tenía nombre y apellido
prenda castró esa niña soy yo
así es cómo llego a mi vida un gran y
doloroso fracaso porque por más que lo
quería y lo intente cuando ya me sentía
mejor ya no pude hacer gimnasia todo el
tiempo estaba temerosa me pasaba de
lesión en lesión
ahora te voy a mostrar como no basta con
querer uno tiene que merecer lo que
quiere lograr bienvenido
al alto rendimiento
llegó a vivir a monterrey a la edad de
los 17 años en el 2004 soy mitad regia
por adopción y amo este estado estudio
en la universidad autónoma de nuevo león
durante ese tiempo hice un poco de
actividades y de vez en cuando algo de
ejercicio estudié me gradué empecé a
trabajar en oficina y en el 2013
un amigo me platica de un nuevo deporte
bien chido era algo llamado cross en
pocas palabras y después de mis primeras
clases prueba de vivirlo y sentirlo de
tomar mi entrenamiento lo entendí como
que era algo que te sea funcional a la
vida diaria combinando varios ejercicios
y deportes
la mayoría olímpicos era muy divertido
variado daba resultados super rápido y
lo mejor de todo una hora de clase y
obviamente como toda buena mujer
vanidosa dije oye una hora de
entrenamiento para tener resultados
físicos tan pronto definitivamente tengo
que probarlo
pero hablaré con los entrenadores porque
obvio no me quería poner grande y tosca
a los tres meses ya estaba compitiendo
al año
y estaba inscrito en el primer
clasificatorio en donde si lo grabas
colocarte dentro de las mejores 40
atletas de latinoamérica podrías ir a
competir al regional y la ganadora tenía
pase directo al mundial de cross fit
logre clasificar como una de las mejores
de méxico qué suerte no digo es lo que
muchos podrían pensar yo también llega a
creerlo porque cuando algo bueno nos
pasa la mayoría de veces se lo
atribuimos a la suerte porque creemos
que las cosas buenas solamente le pasan
a otras personas pero nunca a nosotros
2014 el año de encontrar el como si este
año me hizo darme cuenta que estaba
haciendo algo que me apasionaba
muchísimo pero también me hizo darme
cuenta que mis problemas de espalda
seguían ahí
acudir con los especialistas y el común
denominador era el mismo retirarme del
cross y mi espalda no era lo
suficientemente sana y apta para ese
deporte
pero esas alturas dejarlo ya no era
opción hablé con mi fisioterapeuta sobre
cómo podía encontrar la manera de seguir
entrenando empezamos un tratamiento
aunado a una serie de ejercicios de
fortalecimiento de espalda y abdomen lo
que protegerían de mejor manera mi
columna me servirían como tipo de
rehabilitación y al mismo tiempo me
permitirán seguir entrenando de nuevo
2015 aprender a descansar no a renunciar
seguir participando pero ahora entre un
equipo que integra
2016 rendirse
nunca será opción regrese a participar
de manera individual y vaya sorpresa
logró clasificar de nuevo mis regionales
como la mejor de méxico y de
latinoamérica dios
era la primera vez que una mexicana
estaba en el ranking latino como la
mejor que significó eso éxito muchos
podrán pensar eso
para mí fue una carga enorme si bien
entrenaba durísimo y amaba de
sobremanera lo que hacía nunca creí
llegar a tener ese resultado de la forma
en que llego y como me llegó me puso
nerviosísima mucha gente empezó a
mostrarme su emoción y su apoyo lo que
literalmente llevó a convertirse en una
carga que me enfermaba y digo
literalmente porque de verdad no enfermo
una semana antes de mi competencia me
sentí malísimo el caso es que ese fin de
semana creo que lidia con otro momento
muy difícil mental y deportivamente
hablando
al día 2 de la competencia
y siendo la mejor atleta de
latinoamérica
qué descalificada
de nuevo mi espalda no soporto el peso
por lo que no pude realizar un
levantamiento que era necesario para
seguir en la competencia
mi mundo se desmoronó mi espalda no
solamente no pudo cargar con el peso
físico sino lo emocional
ese día
no sabía si lo que más me dolía era no
poder seguir en la competencia o sentir
el rechazo
y la lástima de tantas personas
pensé en darme por vencida renunciar
cuando uno está en una sesión difícil
tienes dedos te vuelves víctima y te
quedas ahí esperando que se sigan
compadeciendo de ti hasta que se les
olvide o le dejas tu destino a la suerte
chance y después te va mejor o te
levantas analistas- tu problema
tus áreas de oportunidad te prometes
pero sobre todo te comprometes a que
nunca más quieres volver a vivir una
situación así y trabajas para que de
verdad así sea yo opté por la segunda
opción entendí que esto lo hacía por
amor y pasión no por compromiso decidí
borrarme cualquier tipo de estereotipo
acerca de cómo luciría mi cuerpo con
mayor entrenamiento y más disciplina la
alimentación dejó de importarme el verme
bien y empezó a preocuparme al sentirme
bien y convertir mi cuerpo en ese motor
que me ayudará a ir más allá a lograr
mis sueños aunado a esto había hecho mis
ahorritos dejé por completo el trabajo
de oficina para tener más tiempo
obviamente mucha gente me cuestionó me
uní a dos personas que se volvieron mis
socios y abrimos nuestro gimnasio
crossfit y gran mi casa a su casa cuando
gusten
y decidí que quería estar al nivel de
las mejores competidoras del mundo
entonces tenía que hacer lo que sean
ellas analice sus estilos de vida ya qué
competencias iban y sobre todo entrene
durísimo para poder clasificar esas
competencias
además tenía que costear me sola mis
viajes
yo no tenía apoyos de patrocinadores y
soy consciente tal vez no lo merecía lo
suficiente sumándole lo que me acaba de
pasar con mi descalificación
prácticamente nadie cree y él mismo me
puse hacer rifas vendí playeras daba más
clases cursos todo lo que fuera posible
para generar más ingresos
lo logré pudiera varias competencias
internacionales en algunos eventos la
verdad es que me pusieron unas
arrastradas pero en otros me fue muy
bien quizá mejor de lo que me puede
haber esperado que género eso en mi fe
confianza y empecé realmente a creer en
mí
2017 paciencia es la clave con mucho más
nivel más experiencia
sumándole también ahora más motivación
dije ahora sí este año es mi año fui top
20 mundial en el clasificatorio ya todo
perfecto la gente me ha apoyado de nuevo
ya habían marcas de patrocinadores que
se han acercado y lo más importante es
que realmente empecé a creer en mí
empecé a sentir que era posible lograr
el sueño de games de verdad ese año
sentía que el filme iba a ganar me pase
quedé en el lugar 12 de mis regionales
otro fracaso más
híjole fue muy duro la verdad me había
esforzado muchísimo
esta vez no me cuestioné pensé que cada
quien tiene lo que se merece y tal vez
no he llegado al punto de merecerlo
entonces no pasaba nada simplemente
tenía que entrenar más duro
2018 disciplina más trabajo es igual a
resultado en el mejor estado físico de
mi carrera deportiva entrenamientos
diarios de 810 horas todo perfecto dos
semanas antes de mi clasificatorio
sobrecarga en la columna más sumándole
mis problemas de niña era mucho el dolor
y la incomodidad para entrenar eso no me
iba a detener hablé con mi
fisioterapeuta asumir las consecuencias
y decidí infiltrarme unos medicamentos
muy fuertes para ocultar el dolor
resultado top 30 mundial clasificación
como la mejor latina y mi espalda de
nuevo haciéndose presente doble desgarro
en la columna
ese fue el resultado de asumir mi
responsabilidad porque realmente fue mía
de inicio me dijeron que eso podía pasar
pero nadie puede conocerte mejor que tú
mismo uno tiene que ser consciente de
sus decisiones y repercusiones y no
dejarle a alguien más tu futuro porque
si te va bien no te va mal lo más fácil
es culpar a cualquier persona de esa
decisión que al final del día fue tu
decisión
yo tengo un objetivo y estaba decidido a
cumplirlo de cualquier manera y esta es
nuestra realidad de los que hacemos
deporte de alto rendimiento que hoy
estamos bien pero mañana tal vez ni
siquiera podamos levantarnos de la cama
y perder todos esos años y horas de
esfuerzo así
de la nada
tocaba ahora entender el significado de
la palabra resiliencia porque lo más
dramático y estresante de todo esto era
que tenía que estar dos semanas en
reposo absoluto siendo conscientes la
columna es el mayor soporte de nuestro
cuerpo y mi competencia eran cuatro
semanas
tocaba abrirle paso a la pasión el amor
por lo que uno hace llegó el fin de
semana de mis regionales casi nadie supo
algo de mi lesión hubo quienes dijeron
que no lo lograría que podía perder mi
forma deportiva por haber bajado la
carga de esa manera mi cuerpo también me
lo decía a no sentir la misma fuerza y
potencia que tenía bastante hasta antes
de la lesión
pero cuando entré a ese gimnasio grande
donde se llevaría a cabo ese fin de
semana de la competencia
mi mente y mi corazón no dejaban de
repetirme que es el lugar por el que
estaba luchando era mío
que nadie lo deseaba tanto como yo que
nadie lo había sufrido y trabajado tanto
como yo y que pasara lo que pasara así
terminara arrastrándome cada evento iba
a salir a luchar por algo que era mío
y eso hice evento tras evento
y el resultado fue este
de nuevo ser latinoamérica
e
griega
el grafiti tigre es su quinta
participación dos visiones y el 1905 dos
visiones
nuestra representante en latinoamérica
marisol
de pequeña soñé con vivir haciendo el
deporte que me apasionaba hoy vivo de
hacer apasionadamente el deporte que amo
ese fin de semana mi espalda no solo
cargo pepsi barras ese domingo 27 de
mayo del 2018 cargue con los sueños de
mi país
en esta bandera alce los sueños e
ilusiones de una niña que truncó su
ilusión de ser una gran deportista y
cargue con el orgullo y el honor que me
permitió convertirme en la representante
de toda mi nación latina en nuestra
máxima competencia
lo logramos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
las claves son fueron y seguirán siendo
siempre creer para crear encontrar
siempre el como si aprender a descansar
nunca renunciar
cuando te falta motivación sé
disciplinado
ser resiliente sé muy paciente pero
sobre todo hagas lo que hagas no te
olvides de inyectarle amor y pasión a
todo
los sueños están ahí para permitirnos
creer no te prometo un camino fácil pero
te aseguro que cuando te falte
motivación la paciencia disciplina y el
trabajo duro te darán ese empujón extra
que te permitirá no desviarse del camino
el poder de cada persona va más allá de
cualquier límite al igual que esta
palabra engloba más de un significado si
tú crees que puedes sea cual sea tu
situación y esto es un paso adelante
ahora
te toca a ti cargar con el peso de tus
sueños porque sabes que los sueños están
para cumplirse te invito a insistir
a resistir pero sobre todo a nunca
desistir dios los bendiga muchas gracias
[Aplausos]